heute genau in sechs wochen wird gewählt
und die wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch dass
die fdp zum kanzler oder kanzlerin
macher werden wird zeit also für fragen
an den fdp chef christian lindner über
klima corona koalitionen und mehr und
damit herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview herr kohl ich grüße sie
wir begrüßen sie nur wahlheimat berlin
ja man dienstlich bedingten heimat hier
an diesem tollen wasser das hier
ausgesucht habe ein bisschen abseits der
normalen pfade die rummelsburger bucht
eine ausbuchtung der spree im osten der
stadt lich weit von vom politischen
berlin entfernt sie haben heute einer
zeitung hier in berlin ein interview
gegeben und haben gesagt dass teile des
wahlkampfs infantil sein also eher
kindisch oder und bereit ist es nicht
eher so dass große teile dieses
wahlkampfs den großen herausforderungen
dieser zeiten wenn du nicht angemessen
scheint wir meinen das gleiche wir
müssen über die großen themen sprechen
wie gelingt klimaschutz mit technologie
statt mit verboten wie stabilisieren wir
unsere wirtschaftliche basis in diesen
breiten sie mit ihrer kritik mit den
infantilen die nebensächlichkeiten
bürger über kichern von kandidaten und
buchveröffentlichungen mehr diskutiert
wird als über den zustand des
bildungssystems wenn wir bei unreife
sind oder bei noch nicht ganz reif sie
haben selber versucht die zukunft
vorherzusagen
sie haben gesagt sie war das im prinzip
entschieden und armin laschet wird der
nächste kanzler wenn sie sich jetzt die
entwicklung der letzten wochen anschauen
bleiben sie dabei ich glaube der
regierungsbildungsauftrag geht an die
union die frage ist nur in welcher
zusammensetzung dann eine koalition
gebildet wird darüber und andere themen
sollten wir treten dürfen
[Musik]
erlebnis bevor wir zur fdp und ihrem
wahlprogramm kommen müssen wir auf die
drängende frage des tages schauen auf
die dramatische lage in afghanistan ist
der ganze abzug ein gigantischer fehler
ja man muss sich fragen warum das so
unvorbereitet passiert wir müssen auch
evaluieren warum der afghanistan einsatz
über die vielen jahre diese
erschütternde bilanz hat jetzt heute am
tag erwarte ich dass schnell der befehl
erteilt wird dass die deutschen
staatsangehörigen dass die diplomaten
evakuiert werden und im übrigen auch die
ortskräfte also die menschen die dort
für die bundeswehr für den deutschen
staat gearbeitet haben das ist unsere
moralische verpflichtung ist dass ihre
forderung jetzt das ja sagt passieren
muss ja das ist die akute situation und
wir sollten da großzügig sein nicht nur
wegen unserer moralischen verpflichtung
weil
andere auf der welt bei ähnlich
gelagerten situationen doch genau
vergleichen werden wie gehen die
deutschen mit denen um die ihnen
geholfen haben also da sollten der
großzügig sein sind menschen die
sprechen ja auch deutsch und sind bereit
zu arbeiten und es gibt was zweiter die
bundesregierung muss auf der
internationalen bühne jetzt dafür sorgen
dass eine situation die 2015 in syrien
sich nicht wiederholt also mit dem
flüchtlingshilfswerk und anderen
partnern muss im umfeld von afghanistan
jetzt eine infrastruktur aufgebaut
werden um flüchtende menschen dort zu
schützen ihm dort menschenwürdige
umstände zu bieten aber nochmal auf das
große bild dieses einsatzes 20 jahren
afghanistan einsatz auch von der fdp
unterstützt was lehrt es uns
wir haben bereits in den letzten jahren
in den vergangenen vier jahren in denen
wir ja wieder im deutschen bundestag mit
sprechen regelmäßig die bundesregierung
gebeten den einwand einsatz zu
evaluieren und insbesondere uns zu
unterrichten darüber was ist eigentlich
bewirkt worden dabei selbst tragen der
sicherheitsstrukturen in afghanistan
aufzubauen also durch ausrüstung und
durch ausbildung das war offensichtlich
nicht erfolgreich nur weil es hilft es
jetzt darauf hinzuweisen die fdp habe
bereits 2019 dieses oder jenes die
situation ist wie sie jetzt ist wir
müssen für die zukunft lernen und vor
allem jetzt die anstehenden aufgaben bei
dem schutz von geflüchteten damit wir
nicht in situationen wie 2015 erhalten
zu leisten und die akute frage der
evaluierung muss jetzt befohlen werden
zurück zur bevorstehenden bundestagswahl
mit einer hohen wahrscheinlichkeit
werden sie ja zum kanzler oder kanzlerin
macher schwarz grün braucht aktuell nach
den umfragen die fdp ist geht auch eine
deutschland koalition es geht eine ampel
wenn all das am ende möglich ist wenn
dann ende sie die wahl haben das werden
sie wählen wir schauen auf die inhalte
herr kohl und da kann man ganz nüchtern
ja vergleichen nehmen wir die frage der
steuererhöhungen spd grüne und
linkspartei wollen massive
steuererhöhungen die cdu es inzwischen
unklar herr laschet schließt sie nicht
mehr aus wir wollen keine
steuererhöhungen wollen eher entlasten
gestalten sie das zweite beispiel der
schuldenbremse wir glauben dass nach der
pandemie wir dringend wieder solide
wirtschaften müssen spd grüne und
linkspartei wollen die schuldenbremse
auf markus söder liebäugelt auch gerade
damit das heißt es ist er partner aus
die nein aber die csu es da unklaren das
zeigt die fdp hat eine bedeutung die
cdu/csu stehen uns nahe aber sind schon
dabei sich nach links zu orientieren und
die aufgabe der fdp ist es eine weitere
linksverschiebung der deutschen politik
zu verhindern wir sind nämlich schon
links genug und wir haben nicht zu viel
sondern zu wenig freiheit noch mal meine
frage angesichts der möglichen
koalitionsoptionen die sie haben was
würden sie wählen cdu/csu stehen uns am
nächsten
wir regieren ja auch erfolgreich in
nordrhein westfalen wir sind wie ich
gerade dargestellt habe aber nicht
deckungsgleich deshalb erwarte ich eine
regierungsbildung unter führung der
union wegen der des momentums und ich
glaube dass das eine sache der union
wäre dass weitere format zu bestimmen
also diese so genannte jamaika oder
deutschland koalition das wäre ja nicht
an uns
markus söder hat formuliert dass er die
erweiterte mütter rente als rote linie
formuliert ohne würde er nicht in einer
koalition gibt es ähnlich punkte für sie
ja keine steuererhöhungen und kein
aufweichen der schuldenbremse wir haben
jetzt schon enorme lasten bei der
generation der kinder und enkel und wir
beobachten ja bereits inflationsrisiken
und jetzt muss die erste aufgabe sein
ich habe auch sehr viele soziale und
ökologische ziele herkomme über die wir
für gleich auch noch sprechen können
bevor wir aber über soziale und
ökologische ziele und neue
staatsaufgaben sprechen müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass unser wirtschaftliches
fundament wieder stabil ist also der
stadien doch überschuldet ist und wir
auch wieder einen aufschwung in der
wirtschaft sähen mit neuen jobs neuen
unter nur um dieses thema abzuschließen
die koalitionsoptionen fürs protokoll
wenn es eine ampel gebe würden sie auf
einem kanzler olaf scholz bestehen
seines kisten geht nicht um personen
sondern es geht um inhalte und die ampel
ist von den inhalten mit personen ja
aber ja ja gut herr scholz hat in
hamburg einmal die möglichkeit gehabt
sozialliberal zu regieren er hat bereits
vor der wahl gespräch mit der fdp
ausgeschlossen das ist kein
sozialliberaler wie wie helmut schmidt
für uns gilt inhalte zählen und beim
vergleich der inhalt der inzwischen
viele wolken und hirn schon mir fehlt
die fantasie die überhaupt rot und grün
der fdp ein angebot machen könnten die
stehen in der sache der linkspartei ja
viel näher als uns bleiben wir bei den
inhalten zum wichtigsten thema der
menschen bei dieser wahl und in dieser
zeit ist die korona pandemie ihr
stellvertreter wolfgang kubicki hat nach
der jüngsten ministerpräsidenten tagung
der kanzlerin bescheinigt ich zitiere
die saiten ihrer eigenen angst blase
gefangen und habe nicht mehr die
wirklichkeit vor augen die beschlüsse
sind aber natürlich auch mit den
ministerpräsidenten gefasst worden auch
mit ihrem lieblings
kanzler haben ihn laschet wie soll das
denn im anstehenden corona herbst und
winter zusammen mit den liberal in der
runde von bund und ländern ist kein
fdp-mitglied präsent oder dass wir das
miteinander sei in den wäldern ist hier
natürlich vertritt ja aber die
krisenstrategie wird ja in der runde
geprägt und insbesondere vom
cdu-geführten kanzleramt
die pandemie haben wir nie verharmlost
sie es auch nicht überwunden aber der
charakter der pandemie hat sich ja
verändert durch gottlob die erfolge beim
impfen haben wir eine andere situation
deshalb müssen der schrittweise in die
normalität zurück was bedeutet das
weiter tempo machen beim impfen auch
durch mobile angebote es bedeutet dass
geimpfte und gelesen eigentlich keine
weitergehenden freiheits einschränkungen
mehr erdulden müssten von ihnen geht
kein nicht verantwortbares risiko aus
und wir brauchen wir den deutschen
bundestag der mit entscheiden kann das
jetzt noch einmal die sonderbefugnisse
der regierung verlängert werden sollen
das halten wir nicht für angemessen wir
müssen schrittweise in normalität herr
kohl und wir müssen zug um zug die
menschen wieder in die
selbstverantwortung auch für die eigene
gesundheit bringen aber sie sind in
jeder koalitionsoptionen die wir eben ja
kurz beschrieben haben der kleinste
partner wie sollen sie denn die korona
bedingungen die sie gerade formuliert
haben dann durchsetzen wird wir können
nicht unsere eigene politik diktieren
aber wenn sie alleine schleswig holstein
mit einem fdp- gesundheitsminister mit
dem freistaat bayern vergleichen
dort hat es so weit dass die vom bund
vorgegebene strategie möglich gemacht
hat immer eine größere sensibilität für
bürgerrechte gegeben in schleswig
holstein als in bayern wir waren
aufmerksamer für die sozialen für die
gesellschaftlichen und die
wirtschaftlichen schäden der pandemie
bekämpfung man kann als als fdp nicht
der ganzen republik die politik
diktieren aber man kann ein fluss nennen
das zweitwichtigste thema der
wählerinnen und wähler in dieser
bevorstehenden wahl zeit ist die
klimakrise
darüber möchte ich mit ihm reden vorher
aber fast uns thomas reichert die
ausgangslage in 60 sekunden zu sammeln
klimaschutz war bislang kein großes fdp
thema eher im gegenteil dass die fdp
zuletzt den bund regierte wehrte sich
ihr damaliger wirtschaftsminister rainer
brüderle vehement gegen eu-pläne mehr
co2 einzusparen wir müssen uns mehr zeit
lassen und von brüderle 2010 so ging es
weiter mit seinem nachfolger philipp
rösler
statt mehr klimaschutz wurde rösler mehr
kohlekraftwerke zuletzt die klima
proteste christian lindner belehrte die
jugendlichen das ist eine sache für
profis wir können nicht die probleme des
jahres 2040 bereits im jahr 2020 lösen
es geht auch um freie lebensweise dem
wahlprogramm ist die fdp gegen ein
frühes wende von verbrennungsmotoren
gegen subventionen für elektroautos sie
hofft auf klimaschutz durch den markt
reicht nicht sagt profis allein auf den
markt und auf innovationen zu setzen ist
nicht ausreichend da habe ich den
eindruck da wird die fdp in der zeit die
wir haben auch bis 2050 allein mit dem
markt nicht weiterkommt da wäre es
gerade gehört sie setzten beim
klimaschutz auf neue technologien und
auf den markt ich darf ihnen zusätzlich
zu dem eben gehörten potsdamer
klimaforscher noch den früheren chef
ökonom der weltbank sonic listen
zitieren er sagt der klimawandel ist das
größte marktversagen der geschichte dann
haben wir billigprodukte
massenproduktion wegwerf konsum
vermeintlich niedrige energiekosten das
sind doch im grunde die folgen genau des
marktes auf den sie jetzt setzen ich
finde meine position sowohl den beitrag
als auch in ihrer frage gar nicht wieder
den beitrag muss man auch nochmal
faktisch überprüfen rufe mal in
erinnerung damals 2009 2010 hat die von
der fdp mitgetragene bundesregierung die
deutschen klimaziele verschärft die sind
verschärft worden gegenüber dem was von
rot-grün und der vorherigen großen
koalition beschlossen war in der sache
sind wir für ein verbot und
insofern auch ein markteingriff wir sind
für das verbot das zuviel co2
ausgestoßen wird wie aber mit dem dann
noch verbleibenden budget an co2
emission umgegangen wird in der tat da
setzen wir auf erfindergeist da setzen
wir auf die ingenieurinnen und die
techniker in unserem land weil sie und
ich wir beide wir werden hier nicht die
technologisch überzeugende lösungen
finden also in einem satz gesagt wir
wollen mehr freude am erfinden als am
verbieten in unserem land sie habe
gerade in co2 preis und den
emissionshandel genannt die zertifikate
sollen knapper und immer teurer werden
das würde aber wenn man den experten
glaubt den preis durch die decke
schließen lassen aber von den enormen
kosten ließ nur bei ihnen dem programm
nichts also die 16 cent würden bei
weitem nicht ausreichend diskutiert doch
davon liest man tatsächlich wir wollen
zum einen jahr eine sogenannte klima
dividende das heißt das geld das der
staat einnimmt durch den verkauf dieser
co2 rechte das wollen wir nutzen um den
strompreis zu reduzieren also die
eeg-umlage
abzuschaffen und auf der anderen seite
wollen wir ja dieses geld an die
bürgerinnen und bürger direkt auszahlen
das heißt es geht wirklich darum den
marktwirtschaftlichen prozess und der
hat sich nun wirklich historisch und
international jeder zentralen planung
als überlegen erwiesen ich glaube das
kann man nun sagen die frage ist also
dann haben auch die klimamodelle richter
unser modell ist dasjenige das wirksam
aber auch effektiv die klimaziele
erreicht denn wie ich sage aber das ist
im prinzip hoffnung auch in 1 tagen darf
also es sprechen von der finder geist
und in ihrem programm heißt es den
wettbewerb der besten das klingt weil
parallel prinzip hoffnung ist wir machen
den benzinpreis höher und glauben dann
fahren die menschen weniger auto das ist
prinzip hoffnung hatten wir nämlich
schon wir hatten mal eine ökosteuer die
wurde genau deswegen eingeführt sie
hatte keinen effekt unser modell dagegen
sorgt dafür der co2 ausstoß ist
gedeckelt und dann gibt es die zwingende
verpflichtung für die gesellschaft wege
zu suchen und die sind da wenn einmal
ein beispiel die basf möchte vor der
küste ein wasserstoff windpark bauen um
den größten co2 emittenten des landes
ihr chemiewerk in ludwigshafen
klimaneutral zu machen wissen sie was
die fordern nicht subventionen die
wollen auch nicht dass in die zukunft
vertagen die sagen nur 1 bitte schnelle
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren und
da ist unser problem hat ja auch jeder
messebesucher deutschland erfolgen aber
die maßnahmen die es gebe tempolimit aus
für den verbrennungsmotor alles lehnen
sie ab kaufprämie von ihm motor ja weil
in den verbrennungsmotor können wir auch
synthetisches benzin das mit
erneuerbarer energie in chile produziert
wird einfüllen und das müssen wir auch
denn wir haben ja millionen autos auf
den deutschen straßen wenn wir warten
bis die alle durch elektrische autos
ersetzt sind dann haben wir die zeit
verloren wir können also sehr viel
schneller mit technologieoffenheit und
wirklich mit dem vertrauen auf
ingenieurwissenschaftliches know-how
erfolge erzielen und ich füge hinzu
diese verzichts denke der grünen die mag
moralisch ansprechend für uns im
wohlstand hier seien aber glauben sie
allen ernstes china indien afrika
könnten da folgen wir müssen der
technologie weltmeister sein und ich
wünsche mir dass insbesondere cdu und
csu in dieser frage die grünen nicht
mehr länger schonen sondern dass wir
gemeinsam herausarbeiten der verzicht
auf wirtschaftliche perspektive freiheit
bringt uns beim klimaschutz nicht voran
in privater seite stehen und klimakrise
und corinna werden ja den nächsten
jahren enorme finanzielle mittel
brauchen blicken wir deswegen her die
liberale steuer und haushaltspolitik die
summe ihrer vorgeschlagene entlastung in
wahlprogrammen wurden zusammengerechnet
und wären ein minus von fast 90
milliarden euro in den öffentlichen
kassen sie möchten finanzminister werden
aber konkrete vorschläge wie man diese
summe finanziert haben sie nicht gemacht
ja weil wir auch gar nicht sagen dass
die vorschläge alle gleichzeitig in
einem haushaltsjahr wirksam werden
sollen sondern es sind vorschläge die
wir unterbreitet haben die schritt für
schritt umgesetzt werden sollen übrigens
ist das tal errechnete defizit
ebenfalls noch mal zu hinterfragen
residenz genaueres muss vollkommen es
bleibt ja vollkommen unberücksichtigt
das natürlich eine steuerliche
entlastung im effekt der jahre danach
auch zu noch stärkeren wirtschaftlichen
belebung kommt weil die überstunde die
bauordnung
überhaupt tut
weil sie internationalen vergleich hat
gerade das ehren
es gibt aber auch studien aus
deutschland dies klar zeigen ist ja auch
evident wenn die überstunde sich lohnt
wenn es sich lohnt in einem neuen job zu
investieren wenn wir auf den weltmärkten
wettbewerbsfähig sind wenn private
investitionen ausgelöst werden dann
stärkt das natürlich das wachstum und
deshalb wir haben zwei leitplanken keine
steuererhöhungen keine aufweichung der
schuldenbremse und dazwischen wollen wir
arbeiten und gezielten entlastungen von
der von dem krankenpfleger bis zur
ingenieurin im mittelstand und für die
im wettbewerb stehenden betrieb lassen
damit werfen lassen wollen sie wir sind
dann noch mal bei den zahlen des zdg vor
allem die menschen die hohe einkommen
haben wenn man über 300.000 euro
verdient hat man nach ihren steuer
plänen ende 18.000 euro mehr und das ist
proportional natürlich nicht
vergleichbar mit den kleineren 1 das
habe ich zwei antworten die erste
antwort ist wer ein hohes einkommen hat
zahlt allerdings auch mehr steuern in
dieser entlastung ist zudem das ist mein
zweites argument der
solidaritätszuschlag mit enthalten in
wahrheit ist das aber keine entlastung
herr kohl der solidaritätszuschlag denen
wir abschaffen wollen ist aus unserer
sicht verfassungswidrig wir klagen in
karlsruhe
herr scholz hätte niemals mit der
einnahme planen dürfen sagt sogar der
bundesrechnungshof also wegen des
verfassungswidrigen soliden wir
abschaffen wollen ist eher entlastung
zusätzlich größer die sie errechnet
haben und das dritte argument ist
menschen die so ein einkommen beziehen
beziehen das ja oftmals in unserem land
nicht für sich sondern es das einkommen
ihres handwerksbetriebs aus dem auch
dann die wirtschaftliche substanz
erbracht werden muss für die schaffung
eines ausbildungsplatzes oder für neues
gerät erinnert genau in sechs wochen
wird gewählt das heißt geschichte
wiederholt sich nicht aber sie reiben
sich gelegentlich mit blick auf die
akteure und auf mögliche koalition gibt
es auch in diesem jahr eine situation in
der es für sie heißen könnte besser
nicht regieren ja wir haben 2017 jahr
den damals von frau merkel mit den
geplanten links shift unseres landes ich
denke alleine nur an die frage der
einwanderungspolitik damals das haben
wir verhindert und so kann ich auch in
diesem jahr sagen eine weitere
verschiebung nach links weniger respekt
vor eigentum weniger freie
entfaltungsmöglichkeiten höhere
belastungen einen solchen weg könnten
wir nicht mitgehen herzlichen dank für
das gespräch danke ihnen das war unser
sommerinterview mit dem fdp chef
christian lindner am kommenden sonntag
trifft mit der kollegin sharon keller
danner den kanzlerkandidaten der spd
olaf scholz ihnen noch einen angenehmen
und gute nacht
[Musik]